all right we are not alive for July's
AMA that's asked me anything session
hopefully everybody is hearing things
coming through quite well I got
everything set up here with my coffee I
see a number of questions already in the
chat let me fix it so that it's live
chat rather than just top chat and looks
like a lot of people have added like
three or four questions so I'm going to
take one from each person rather than
going through them sequentially in order
to be be fair about things so let's say
Ken Kimes has three questions up
actually four at the start I'm going to
take one of them so I'll actually take
only part of one of them I'll take part
of his first one who are five
contemporary living philosophers that I
think are saying something compelling an
important or whose work is significant
and could you summarize why you think
they're important it might this might be
a little short on the summarization part
so I'll say right off the bat you know
most of these are gonna be people in
virtue ethics because that's that's what
I do a good bit of my my work or moral
philosophy so that's you know and
they're people who I tend to read so to
begin with let's you know say Alistair
McIntyre still alive he's gonna be
turning 90 I think either he is that 90
already or is he's turning 90 there's a
conference for him down a Notre Dame
commemorating that which unfortunately I
can't get to because of all my work
obligations but I'd love to be there for
that still you know brilliant and very
important thinker on somebody else who
I've had the good fortune to also be
engaged with who I like quite a bit also
as a person as Christopher Gill he's got
a new book out on the self and
Hellenistic philosophy very important
somewhat understated character in in the
field of ancient philosophy so he's not
he's not as mad
but he is a senior scholar who else
would I put in there I mean most of the
people that I'm picking are all at the
senior scholar stage Julia anise is
another one she's got a lot of great
books and articles out on ancient
philosophy and philosophy as a way of
life although she doesn't usually phrase
it like that but she is doing that in
the process which by the way so is Chris
Gill and so it's Alistair McIntyre who
else do I would I direct your attention
towards somebody who's a bit younger
who's doing quite a bit of work here and
there a lot of it in terms of
translations Margaret graver she's got a
really wonderful book on stoicism and
emotion out that I think everybody
should should take a look at and then
who else am i engaging with quite a bit
you know it's interesting I'm doing this
business ethics class online and so I've
actually been reading a lot of Robert
how do all people somebody is you know
very very smart again older scholar made
a lot of contributions all across the
field so those be five people well worth
checking out
cringe favorite film adaptation of a
book that's that's tough because
sometimes I watch a movie and I don't
actually realize that it was a book in
the first place they're gonna get a
little bit more light going in this area
so yeah that's a good good question
favorite I would guess that you know
maybe I think the dualists was in fact
I'm not a is it a book yeah it's cuz
it's based on on Pushkin right and I
think it is based on Pushkin but at the
Ridley Scott movie the duel is one of my
favorite movies of all time just
gorgeous
landscapes beautiful soundtrack great
story great acting
I would I would check that out let's see
here oh this is a good one June 10 no
gusto I heard a professor very
confidently assert that there is really
no theory of the forms in Plato it was
superimposed by later thinkers how
justified is this claim well if you read
Plato not justify it at all you'd have
to throw out everything from you know
the Phaedo and the Republic forward
wouldn't you because it's very clear
that there are force and Plato
I mean it's mentioned as such and it
shows up in dialogue after dialogue now
you could say that there's no theory of
the forms and as such in earlier
dialogues depending on you know the
chronology that you you accept but
that's a I mean it's a laughable claim I
don't know why your professor would make
that that's the sort of thing that
cranks a sort of like the people who are
like you know Jesus Christ never existed
or you know
Socrates never exists we've no
historical evidence for them and you're
like come on you know it's one thing to
say maybe this character wasn't
precisely like what they're being
presented as and talk about you know you
know reconstructions later on but it's a
whole nother thing to make these
sweeping bombastic claims I mean what
evidence would there be that later
thinkers create the theory of the forms
right that's another problem with these
these claims that oh I've got the secret
teaching and I know more than everybody
else usually they're they're not based
in any any good evidence that doesn't
require you to buy into half of the
conspiracy theory to begin with
Shefali con what is one of the most
convincing arguments in your opinion for
and against the existence of God well I
don't think people are usually convinced
by arguments just by themselves there
are always arguments within a context
which might you know for a lot of people
who are like that you know reason logic
types there's well that's no good you
know well that's the way people are
actually convinced of nearly everything
in their life so I actually think the
ontological argument
is provided by ants almost pretty good
as its reformulated and say Spinoza or
the 20th century people that are writing
about it and trying to turn it into you
know perfect being theology or something
like that I think it's a whole different
ballgame but the UNAM argumentum isn't
just proving that God exists it's
proving all these other things as well
and it requires you to sort of like go
into it and I find it you know most of
the time I mean I go back and forth I've
talked about this many times before I go
back and forth quite a bit but so have
many other you know I won't place myself
in the rank of great thinkers but some
great thinkers who have thought about
the argument have also gone back and
forth like that as well all right a
piggy pig-pig I just read sart's nausea
at the end of the book the self-taught
man turns out to be a paedophile why did
start do that is it to show all people
have a dark side um I don't know
you know I there may be some bit of
information out there that I'm not privy
to where start actually talks about the
motivations for for doing that I think
it's the self-taught man is is a sort of
a humanist and Sartre is attacking a
certain kind of humanism and he's trying
to show it you know you could have you
could have been all sorts of things
other than a pedophiles he's trying to
show that the in that character that
many people who put on a mask of
humanism are actually kind of bastards
deep down inside and and you know sörman
any of the people who criticize humanism
is well if we if we want to go there -
alright I'm gonna scroll down and find
some things by other people asking
questions and maybe we'll come back to
some of the other questions that piled
up before but generally it's good you
ask a question I'll get to your question
but you can't ask like eight in a row or
something all right
um let's see the next person in line
would be
jongo henkaa if I remember correctly
Damon shot david chalmers said somewhere
he hadn't read that much [ __ ] which is
interesting for someone who is basically
the consciousness guy
I don't know that Chalmers is not
consciousness guy I'll admit I've read
very little Chalmers and I've read a lot
about consciousness so you know and when
it comes down to it so the bigger
general point when it comes down to it
nobody can read everything that's out
there and you can't even read more than
just a small part of what's out there
and if you want to really specialize you
know meaning go deep into something it's
it's very rare that you find people who
are more than one trick pony's so you
know I mean I read [ __ ] but I read can't
sometimes because I enjoy his stuff and
sometimes because I'm going to teach it
but I'm not I'm definitely not a conch
in and you know I'm not going to say
that that Chalmers his work isn't you
know adequately taking consciousness
into account because he hasn't read much
con maybe he's read other people I don't
know I don't haven't read enough
Chalmers to actually know I can tell you
that that Cueto F and there are
philosophers who are set back a bit by
not reading people I've pointed some
things out like that over the years
where for example in analytic what do
they call that now it's a virtue
epistemology right there's this whole
realm of virtue epistemology a lot of
what they're doing is rehashing things
from the ancients and medievals without
realizing it and they're also not not
grasping because they don't read these
people
that's a phenomenologist of value might
have something to do with that where
people in the critical thinking movement
might have something to do with it and
you know there's there's two responses
when you point this out one response is
the sort of the generous response and
like oh yeah they're doing something
interesting I wish I had the time to
look into him because we're all there
are pretty busy people once we get you
know careers and get going graduate
school it's a whole different ballgame
you got tons and tons of time to do what
you want there but of course you have no
money and you have you know anxiety
about your prospects so that that you
know and you may have to work a job -
but not a job like like later on the
other response is like oh we don't care
we're gonna you know close off our thing
I mean you get that response sometimes -
but more often than not in my experience
and it could just be how I approach
people I usually get the I much more
often get the oh that's that's
interesting that so-and-so is doing that
the more you call it respect for
pluralism response in philosophy all
right let's see 0:45 what do you play -
there's a lot wrong due to the being
some of the earliest recorded
philosophers in effect and later
philosophers for them started off with
those ideas oh okay I see what you're
asking so what things do I think that
Plato and Aristotle not only got wrong
but then an established sort of a
precedent for for later stuff
I mean Aristotle's got a glaring problem
with you know women slaves barbarians
not being capable of full rationality
right and this goes away in later
thinkers because almost all the later
thinkers are barbarians by Aristotle
standard right very few of them are
actually Greeks from from Greece or
Ionia or perhaps Macedonia would get
throw it in there right because
Aristotle himself is from there but the
the you know the the the stuff about
women which Plato by the way didn't fall
into read Plato's Republic right women
have the same capacities as men do same
capacities for rationality for thumos
for emotions all those sorts of things
Aristotle's attitude went on for for
quite a while so that would be one
example and you see you know somebody
like Mary Wollstonecraft having to
criticize her own you know
contemporaries like like you know
Rousseau and Burke and people of that
time she doesn't spend all that much
time on Aristotle but but it's sort of
part of the the culture for a long time
I mean what other mistakes you know
you know the the cosmology and and
physics that that Aristotle has which is
not unique to Aristotle I mean you see
similar things in the Stoics you see
similar things probably if we had
Epicurus --is on nature we'd see a lot
of similar stuff in there as well you
know but those are you know those are
things that they they did their best
attempts at understanding the cosmos
that they live in and its relation to us
human beings and then it was later
outmoded by better science so you know
there's there's quite a bit of that if
you buy into Heidegger right you've got
this ethical metaphysics and you know
Plato represents one kind turning away
from pre-socratic philosophers and their
insights about truth is as revealing
which is more Heidegger than those you
know ancient philosophers I would say
Heidegger is telling a story where he's
sort of the central figure in it right I
mean Nietzsche also has some things to
say about that - right so Plato and
Aristotle well you know I mean each has
a sort of you've got an interesting
attitude towards Plato Platonism you
know like you know theory the forums and
all that sort of stuff but that's
because it's very Socratic he credits
Plato as a poet as being in this tragic
situation where he's you know
essentially Greek literature as burned
itself out in your Ripa teas and later
tragedy people like Agathon about the
new comedy and Plato cobbles together a
new art form the platonic dialogue but I
mean that's sort of a rambling answer to
that all right
Nazim - Jada do I think in nation state
and enforced borders are inherently
oppressive or immoral no they're not
inherently oppressive or immoral but
you're gonna be hard for us to find
border crossings where sooner or later
somebody doesn't make it oppressive
right and something could be oppressive
without being necessarily
you know I think that that nation-states
do in fact have a legitimate need for
security very often that winds up
turning into a security mentality you
know we noticed that for example in our
own border guards in the South there's
this very very nasty virulent racism
that's been there for a very long time
that doesn't just have to do with race
it has to do with exercise of power
against people that that you can abuse
with Martin largely with impunity and
it's not just this current
administration all this this
administration has severely worsened it
it's sort of like there is already you
know disease there and this
administration took away all the
possible medicine and you know added a
whole bunch of crap to the system to
make the disease worse on purpose I
would say just you know for the sake of
some commentators are putting how
cruelty is the the motive behind it
cruelty especially of the people who are
drawn to that sort of mentality but it
was there to begin with you know the
previous administrations had had done
that as well I was you know I remember
driving to to Toronto from New York and
getting to the border and you know you
used to be crossing the border to Canada
was nothing right and we got pulled off
and questioned and all that and I was
like the hell's going on here and now
what I was going through is just teeny
teeny teeny little inconvenience and you
know suspicion and stuff like that
compared to what a lot of people go
through that so many other borders so
you know we can think about how can we
make this fair how can we make this
better how can we make this less immoral
but you do have to have some controls it
can't just be hey anybody goes wherever
the hell they want you know that's not
gonna work so all right let's see what
we got here
Zorba what's the future of philosophy
since less students are choosing it as a
career I don't know that less students
are choosing it as a career do you mean
less students are majoring in philosophy
we'd probably have to look at the stance
on that and that's probably going to be
from
to country to country I'm not sure where
you're based but here in America we
still have plenty of philosophy majors
in part because you know they get hired
you know philosophy majors generally
tend to score highest on the LSAT the
prep you for law school higher than you
know the pre-law students or the Poli
Sci students you know they get jobs and
businesses that want people along with
other people in the humanities they want
people who could actually write a memo
read a memo make an argument carry out
an analysis that unfortunately the
business people and the hard science
people often aren't being especially the
communications people aren't learning
how to do so I don't I don't I don't
know that the premise is actually true I
think that you know there's certainly
less academic positions in philosophy or
many of the academic positions that are
available are not ones that are that are
really sustainable for a person who
wants to earn a living solely by being a
college professor but I don't actually
see that as a bad thing you know I've
been outside of the traditional Academy
although still teaching here and there
for almost 10 years now and I I chose
granted I I did it you know so that I
could be with my now wife living in the
same place but I chose to leave a
position where I was up for early tenure
and promotion and I'd moved into
administration and was being groomed to
actually run a ten year quality
enhancement plan process and I did that
in Park as I thought well you can't
actually live outside of the Academy and
and that's that's where things are gonna
go and that'll be you know reversion to
the norm you think that in in most of
history we had all sorts of philosophy
professors no we had them where there
were universities and a lot of people
did philosophy sort of on the side
Machiavelli is a great example right he
had a day job even Descartes who did
teach in a university for a short time
he's you know doing what he's doing on
his own mostly science actually not
philosophy so much Hume made a living he
never got it back
position that he wanted he made his
living writing history and literary
criticism so you know the it's quite
possible to conduct yourself in
philosophy without having to select the
Academy all right let's see here look
just skipped a little bit okay
anonymous 101 s I would like to hear
your thoughts about the Austrian School
of Economics what do you disagree with
them on or agree with them on I think
they're very reductionist that's that's
pretty much all I need to say about that
and and the people who are like big on
them you know it's sort of like you know
you've got you get very often the case
you get the thinker's another fans and
almost anytime somebody brings up
Austrian School of Economics I'm like
rolling my eyes slightly inside of my
head thinking oh great more of this you
know because the people who tend to be
superfans usually our hard core
libertarians that frame frame themselves
as classical liberals and are very
adamant about the need to like you know
changes change our structure to have
more deregulation and more market forces
and you know I think that you know if
this is going to continue I mean it's
not like we don't have institutions and
think tanks out there already pushing
this stuff all the time Cato Institute's
great example you know you're gonna find
plenty of people really big on that in
there so that's probably enough about
that one oh nice at retro gamer 71
Thanks continuing to enjoy your work
immensely hope you can cover John Henry
Newman taxonomy of the concept it is
grammar of a sentence impossible future
the path are we doing possible world
semantic stuff with the possible future
and you know in some world I'm already
covering it
but that doesn't help you because you
can't get YouTube videos from other
possible world
imagine if though that we're gonna all
answer the thing in a minute but let's
go off on a riff about that imagine you
know per sci-fi hypotheses that we
actually did have what Rick and Morty
were calling transdimensional cable
right and then we could tune into it
through YouTube now it would make it
would make you know classification of
things you really tough you'd have to
figure out exactly what dimension or
what possible world things are coming
from but you know it would certainly
wide and it would it would solve my
problem oh saying you know I should have
done videos on this a while ago I wish
I'd gotten to them I was just like you
know find the Greg who actually did
those videos and then copy them and
because I'm you know so reasonable I
wouldn't get you know too defensive with
myself I you know send an email to
myself and that in that in a world and
say listen I know that you know you did
the videos on Newman a while back do you
think I could have the downloads of them
so I could upload them into my channel
so I don't have to shoot them myself and
the very reasonable Greg over there
would say yeah that's that's fine you
know so long as you know you're not
going to encroach on on my channel over
here doesn't you know it's perfectly
fine hey you know and then what could I
have from your side you know and of
course they'd probably be like some Greg
because we're talking about like every
possible outcome there'd be some Greg
who is a total slacker who'd only shot
like maybe one or two videos but at this
point right if you wouldn't I don't know
that we'd actually trade with that guy
but you know the rest of us would maybe
form a consortium but I should you know
I actually write that up as a story that
could be kind of an interesting science
fiction story so John Henry Newman it's
been a while since I've been reading him
read him a lot back in in the early
2000s as I was doing my dissertation on
blown doubt who was certainly in it you
could say not not so much influenced by
Newman in the sense of drawing ideas
directly from him but they are all in
that same current
and so yeah Newman is an interesting guy
I actually have have a few friends who
are in the I think it's the John Henry
Newman Society and they get together
have conferences every year and I've
never been able to go I always thought
it would be kind of fun to do that so
yeah definitely I mean so those of you
who aren't privy to what retro gamers
talking about right John Henry Newman
was a British you could call him I guess
the best word for him its theologian but
he's also really a philosopher as well
educational theorist communications
theorist really interesting guy starts
out as an Anglican makes his way into
the Roman Catholic Church if you if you
ever go to like college campuses in the
United States and you see a Newman
Center that's named after John Henry
Newman right
the Newman Center is a place for for
Catholic students to go in secular
universities so really yeah that's a
great idea I'll certainly think about it
maybe maybe I mean my video production
for this fall is pretty well set because
I'm teaching all these classes that I
need core concept videos for it and I
don't have Newman in the mix but maybe
in the spring would be would be possible
all right let's find out where things
were skipping around human evolution I'm
going to take the second one because the
translations of epic use I don't have a
favorite translation I don't have
favorite translations in general because
I can you know things I can read in the
original I'm lazy I go to the original
you know whenever something seems kind
of wonky but so okay which text of
Cicero touch on stones is a good
question so it depends on what you're
interested in so if you're if you're
looking for stoic cosmology and theology
on the nature of the gods book - if
you're looking for ethics
there's a real short work which is
called the stoic paradoxes that you want
to check out then there's on duties
available in three books which actually
tells us a bit about controversies
between different stoic thinkers on
issues like you know do you have to
reveal to the market that you know
prices are gonna go up or down or things
like that based on what's what's going
on
of course there's on the ends book three
is is Cato presenting the stoic
philosophy than Cicero critiquing stoic
philosophy if you're interested in stoic
epistemology you want to read the
academics there's there's good bits of
stoic stuff in the AMA laws and on the
Republic coming up as well I'm sure I'm
forget although how can I forget
stoic theory of the emotions stoic
attitudes towards death and injuries and
and things like that
postulant disputations so you know
that'll that'll take you quite a while
to read through all of those sources and
I think I'm leaving something out but I
can't remember off the top of my head
unfortunately so okay so here's a here's
a question that got flagged for review
I'm gonna show it a very funny question
hey Greg is from Robertson's who are the
biggest jerks you've had to deal with in
your academic career in philosophy big
aliens the Heidegger Ian's the
conscience the Didion's the me Chien's
etc I would say it wasn't any
continental people although you know
some some people who are like sue there
there was a time when Dario I was riding
high and there was a lot of people who
are durians and some of them were kind
of jerks the question that you want to
ask is which philosophical movements and
which thinkers and texts tend to a draw
in the jerks who are already jerks and
they're attracted to that Nietzsche I
think is somebody like that
right I'd rant great example right
plenty of people are like I want to read
that stuff that tells me I can tell
everyone else to screw off you know but
then there's some that as their they're
doing it they they kind of become jerks
right and then there's also like
communities of jerks so I would say you
know early in my career it was the
analytic philosophers because they were
still kind of riding high at Southern
Illinois University where I did my like
graduate studies we had a pluralistic
Department but it wasn't everybody all
getting along in one big kumbaya moment
the analytics for years had tried to
phase out the classical American and
continental philosophers so you know you
don't often get this kind of I'm sure I
don't know what you're talking about
condescension coming from them analytics
have gotten better in recent years I
mean there's jerks there's jerks
everywhere right there's plenty of
continental jerks too but I don't see so
much of a problem with with them these
days in part because they don't even
speak the same language you know
themselves it's no longer really like a
research program or closely connected
research programs it's just a way of
doing philosophy I think for them I will
say one thing though when I was at
Southern Illinois University the people
that really got on my nerves the most
were the do Ian's and and I still kind
of you know again that sort of like I
roll on the back of my head when
somebody starts bringing up doing his
pedagogical theory
I like American pragmatism I like James
I like purse I like Royce doing not so
much and and there's something almost
triumphalist ik about do Ian's that
tends to push me away so there's that
and I you know I met quite a few jerks
just people who are personally jerks in
in my light years but whether its
associated with a particular
philosophical bent that's that's a bit
different
all right or eat Scrabble go says I know
it's been asked a thousand times are you
a practicing Catholic like you frequent
the sacraments and attend Mass every
Sunday no I don't I count myself a
Catholic but I I go infrequently and
when I go I'm usually not taking
communion but just you know regarding
the host the way a lot of people did in
the Middle Ages and you know I've got my
own sort of struggles that I have to
work through which I'm not going to lay
out here I'll just say that there's
there's many ways in which em you know I
I'm wrestling with with God you could
say and I'm not quite quite finished
with that yet I will say this too that I
you know watching Catholic politics play
itself out is an entirely unedifying
spectacle that doesn't keep me away but
it certainly doesn't bring me back and I
can see why it's such a scandal for for
so many other people as well but I'm but
I'm certainly a part of the you could
call it the Catholic intellectual
tradition and I do other things
I pray you know I read things along
those lines so alright let's see who
else we got here I do Django before yeah
I did Brian is it Aitchison I am a
laundress by for Allister McIntyre and
wondered if he could talk more about the
seminar you attended with him they had
talked about Lacan trying to understand
Lacan more that's a tough road
well let me say something about the
second part first right yeah Lacan is is
tough to understand my advice for
studying Lacan don't go right into the
Acree all right read some of the
seminars first and I think a great place
to start is the seminar on the ethics of
psychoanalysis you can start with
seminar one if you want seminar - that's
good
seminars are easier to understand
because lacasa in the process of
actually teaching people to some degree
they're easier to understand I think
then are the bak Lacan deliberately
wrote in an obscure way he's kind of a
jerk when it comes down to it in terms
of his writing he was often trying to
stick it to the the psychoanalytic
establishment by the ways in which he
was writing and he does all these plays
on words so so if you're finding him
difficult no no you no reason why you
shouldn't the other thing to keep in
mind too is he's got all these like
diagrams and graphs you could actually
ignore that that stuff I think a lot of
the time and and you know still
understand what he's talking about he
made very unconventional use of
mathematical and topographical symbols
and if you're trying to interpret it in
terms of like the systems that he's
working from it kind of screwed you know
it'll make it difficult for you that
said you know it's worth reading the
agree oh so let's go back to the
MacIntyre thing right so yeah it was
kind of interesting when when I did it I
think it was 2005 so we're talking about
14 years ago so I was a junior scholar I
graduated you know with my PhD in 2002
and I don't know where I saw the call
for applications but I saw it and it
said you know Erasmus Institute summer
fellowship at Notre Dame at that time I
was living in northwestern Indiana so
that would mean I could actually you
know I at that time you know it might my
daughter was probably around three or so
so I didn't want to be gone too long and
I could drive there so I applied for it
and the thing was rationale it was it
was a practical rationality was the the
overarching theme and MacIntyre was
doing his usual three thing his usual
three comparison thing where he goes
like here's tradition one here's
tradition - here's tradition 3 what are
they
to say to each other how can they learn
from each other so the first one that he
picked was rational choice theory which
has its you know beginnings in a sort of
anthropology that that he saw as coming
out of Hobbes and Hume and then you know
it's kind of a common way of
adjudicating moral issues now then the
second one was Aristotelian Thomism so
of course we're reading Aristotle and
you know Thomas Aquinas
and the third one was Freud and Lacan
but he actually brought in quite a lot
of object relations theory and and I was
talking about people other than just
frightened look on but that's a
tradition as well and MacIntyre long had
a grounding he's got a book the
unconscious right which he wrote if you
read the foreword he wrote that while
he's you know teaching a class on on
psychology that he got tasked with doing
sort of out of the blue so I was
probably the most junior scholar there
and I got in in part because I actually
had some background in all three of
those paths and I was teaching at
Indiana State Prison turns out MacIntyre
wanted to talk with me about what prison
teaching was like and what was going on
with that most of the other people who
were involved in the seminar were either
well versed in the Aristotelian Thomas
tradition or they're well versed in the
you know rational choice theory there
was a guy who's an economist there right
Iran Smith and then there were a few who
like Newt ohm ISM stuff to some degree
but also knew some continental stuff so
I was there I think that you know be
somebody who could be a sounding board
for that the seminar was we we were
given you know a reading list way ahead
of time and it included some books on
rational choice theory some Hume stuff
some Hobbes stuff Mac enterin of
bringing in some Pascal as well talking
about you know the the wager and and how
you know we can do things
that way in terms of like breaking down
problems that way and then of course
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics politics
your Dameon ethics large parts of Thomas
Aquinas is works
he is the Ralph McInerney that big thick
reader that's available and then I don't
remember what we had from Freud quite a
few things and then Lacan you
recommended a ke seminar seven ethics of
psychoanalysis some secondary works as
well and each morning we would get
together what was cool we have we all
get put in the same dorm at Notre Dame
so we're there for two weeks very
intensive we eat together right for
breakfast all of us at not McIntyre he
lives off campus and then we meet in a
room and then from 9:00 to 12:00 were
there with McIntyre and he's leading the
seminar then you know we break for lunch
all eat lunch together and then in the
afternoon from like one to five
sometimes six it's us doing
presentations and McIntyre giving
feedback and all of us you know going
back and forth about this stuff and then
at night you know we're like either
going out and hanging out together in my
case I was actually at the library a lot
doing research for my book on the
Christian philosophy debates but and
then I didn't stay the weekend actually
went back home for the Saturday so I
could see my daughter and then came back
but yeah it was it was it was good it
was that way for both weeks we and we're
each had our project and then after the
seminar we could have follow-ups with
McIntyre if it was Ave if he was
available at the time and so I had some
follow-ups with him and why was he
interested in Lacan so you know like I
put it out Freudianism the Freudian
approach to things is is a sort of
tradition in moral philosophy and if you
strip aside the stuff like the Oedipus
complex and all that there's still
something there there's still something
to the idea of doing track therapy
understanding our unconscious
motivations having desires that were not
really privy to
figuring out how we would come to terms
with them and lock ah is is really
reacting against the Freudians of his
own time who are getting into ego
psychology and stuff like that he wants
it we got to go back to Froy and
McIntyre was also interested in
childhood development this is you know
the stuff that is you know coming out of
as well you know his great big set of
books is you know after virtue whose
justice which rationality three rival
versions that's often viewed as the
trilogy but then there's dependent
rational animals and in there he's
talking about the virtues of knowledge
knowledge dependence that's coming out
of psychological theory on his part so
he thinks that it's important to take
that into account and you know McIntyre
thought there was a great deal of
nonsense look but there was also a lot
of stuff that an Aristotelian Thomas
would want to take on and he's not
unique in that Leslie cozy AK has a
really wonderful article on Aristotle
called on being properly affected
everybody should read it
towards the end cozy Act says already
known as a quote that sorry Coleman
Leslie Coleman says if we wanted to take
a risk to Tilian theory further we have
to acknowledge that there's other ways
of understanding the self and working on
the self that we would need to connect
up with virtue ethics namely spiritual
counseling and sight you know something
like psychoanalysis I think that's part
of what McIntyre was after in that
seminar all right Jesse Circuit who are
contemporary Cicero's that depends on
whether you're asking who's doing good
eclectic philosophy or who are
philosophers involved with our political
crises and and state and stuff like that
and it's important if we're going to say
that somebody's in Cicero they're not
going to be a johnny-come-lately person
they're gonna have been within the
political system for quite a while
moving up through through the ranks I I
don't know that's something I'd have to
think about more people doing good
eclectic work where they actually
understand the traditions with the
drawing on and they're fusing together a
greater synthesis I would say some of
the thinkers who I mentioned earlier in
this session and and I'd say ousted
MacIntyre himself is doing that that
sort of thing Robert Sims is Charles
Taylor is a secular age 800-page Tom
worth reading do I think he's right in
describing secularism and all the self
as understood it's been a while since I
I read it it's worth reading yeah I mean
in a book that long you better find
something that you don't agree with
right otherwise I don't know there's
there's there's maybe a problem there if
you can't find something that you you
know don't don't disagree with but he's
certainly giving you a lot to think
about so yeah I would I would check it
out base prophet hello professor Saylor
do you think humans Anan cognitivist or
a cognitivist and what position do you
hold I'm not a nest so I usually you
know reject those sort of reductive
titles which usually come out of
analytic philosophy and they're like
everybody fits them too you know they're
like these these things there are two
kinds of people in life right it's sort
of like it is Locke a rationalist Stern
empiricist I know if you read his work
he's actually both right because there's
a lot of rationalist elements you can't
like truly be entirely a non-cognitive
this when it comes to moral theory if
there's there's a limit you know at a
certain point and it's you have a
problem with with self-reflection
I mean Hume is definitely putting forth
an ethics that has some important non
cognitive missed parts to it right but
he also thinks that you can in fact
evaluate passions so long as they're not
just passions but involve something like
judgments you know so he's not he's not
totally that but he is is important in
that that framework derek vows or any
good books or thinkers on the philosophy
of perception i've read will
fish I don't know William fish I mean
one of the classic phenomenological
works is merleau-ponty the phenomenology
of perception I like that I'm working
through that with a client you know
heidegger's being in time is about
perception in part too but it's not
something that I really work that much
on I'm you know I'm not much of an
epistemology you know or theory of
perception person so I don't I don't
have a lot of great suggestions Quinn
Pascal do you have any advice texts
recommendations on the art of
memorization especially for philosophy I
don't because my path that I took was
quite idiosyncratic when I needed to
memorize stuff I made myself memorize
stuff I didn't use anybody's techniques
or manam exhorting you know I was a
different kind of kind of person for me
it's easier to understand and retain
things if I understand the system that
they're part of so like when it came to
you know when studying Greek I didn't
just memorize paradigms I learned the
linguistic laws by reading the grammars
that the paradigms were an expression of
and that I would be able to sort of
extrapolate from that so you know I I
don't I don't really have suggestions
cambric do I have any opinions on Terri
Pinker's translation of the
phenomenology of spirit yeah I'm glad
he's got it out I've got an old version
of it when he used to have drafts
available where you've got the the
German and the English on facing pages
and that's awfully nice to have isn't it
so you can actually check the stuff it's
closer to the text than the Miller
translation was let alone the Findlay
translation so it's an advance on it
Miller has got kind of a you know it's
been out there for so long that it's
it's really still the standard text and
it's not like I'm gonna shift it with
the half hour Hegel series to using ping
Kurt's version but you know it's great
that he put in the time to do it I I
know how long translation project
take you know and translating a work
like the phenomenology of spirit man
that is that is a lot to do and it took
in years and years and years and years
yeah McGill Hernandez asks what are my
political alignments so I am you could
say non-aligned but rather you know
critical right now more critical of the
right than the left in the past that's
been that's been the opposite and this
this particular administration and what
they've done and and you know living
here in Wisconsin and seeing what the
Republicans did in our state and and not
just that but the motives behind it has
meant that that practically speaking I'm
going to be supporting the the left in
in you know coming elections and I'm you
know I'm a registered independent I
criticize people pretty routinely from
from all different sides because I'm a
virtue ethicists so that's my my
political alignment unfortunately due to
the sort of you know metastasizing of
trumpism on the right there's very few
people who meet any standards of virtue
left within the Republican Party or
within their their coalition's you look
at evangelicals you look at conservative
Catholics they've all had to like you
know reconfigure their minds in such
ways as to make themselves quite vicious
pull that on left as well but you know
it's revolting for the you know the
littler evils in this case I guess we
could say that in general you know I'm
you know you from an American
perspective a lot of the things that I
endorse are considered leftist from a
European perspective they're pretty
centrist like say protecting workers
rights you know that
you know here in a lot of states we have
a very little of that but that's because
our country's so screwed up I you know I
look at a lot of the Tiff's in between
different constituencies and I think you
know I'm tempted to say a pox on all
houses but I can't do that because we
really Singlish before that we need to
deal with like for example climate
change you know we have we have one
party that's still in complete denial
about it and doesn't want to do anything
and if anything wants to turn things
backwards in terms of protection for the
environment or you know initiatives that
would move us away from high dependence
on fossil fuels we have a democratic
party that's largely captive to
corporate interests and then you know a
lot of the people on the Left are
concerned about it but they're concerned
about it in the ways that wackos are so
you know what are you gonna do and we
have no viable third parties in part
because of the way the system is set up
here a third party can't get into the
debates barely can get on the ballot and
in any meaningful way can't develop
organizations because both parties have
colluded in effect to make that the case
the gerrymandering that happens like
here in Wisconsin where we have a you
know Republican majority in the
legislature even though Republicans are
definitely not the majority it didn't
get the majority of the votes it doesn't
just hurt Democrats it hurts us
independence and it hurts everybody else
because it makes things inherently on
democratic so I guess you could say my
political alignments are I'd like to see
[ __ ] torn down and replaced with much
more democratic institution you know and
I don't see any percent of the current
crop of politicians what is pasture and
gotten rid of and I think the corrosion
and the you know lobbying and all of the
you know sort of backroom deals I think
those are those are bad but again Louis
said I'm a virtue ethicists right so I'm
probably going to be seen as a little
bit unrealistic value by many people all
right
original Bon Jovi do you think the idea
that God is immanent is coherent it
certainly strikes me as incompatible
with classical metaphysics I don't know
which classical metaphysics we mean I
mean Thomas Aquinas was a classical
method physician and he certainly does
seem to think that God could be do
things you know imminently meaning in
the world even if there's even room for
that in Descartes I guess in a way all
right so do I think the idea is it is
coherent it's coherent whether it it
works or not you know when we get down
to I don't know it depends on what
theory we're looking at Natalie asks why
does why do many people seem to have
somewhat nihilistic perspective on life
nowadays is the appeal of Neil ISM
justifiable
I don't know that more people today have
a nihilistic perspective than in the
past I mean I grew up in the 70s and 80s
and 90s and there are plenty of people
who had variety of nihilistic
perspectives back then you can also see
it the popular culture of the time and I
don't think there's a reason why people
are Neil lists or adopt positions that
even though they don't identify as Neil
list are turn out to be Nia list but I
also say that at any given time the lot
of people are you know buying into some
sort of ism in such a way that it's
really it's really an Ania list ik way
you know to go back to politics I'll
take two things from one from right and
one from left if you're Pratt if your
practice of identity politics on the
left is such that you are just sort of
like trying to get you know a charge out
of being the victim and you're you're
you know perfectly fine in your
university dorm room and you go out and
and you know be edgy here and there and
then immediately talk about how you're
you're oppressed and nobody else can
speak for you you're probably an e list
when it comes down to it because what
you're believing in it's kind of
[ __ ] I mean this is this is part of
a like old left people like Marxists are
like what the hell is this crap you know
on the right you know a lot
you know we'll take another example if
you're an evangelical and you support
Trump your analyst that's all there is
to it because what he is doing is so
radically incompatible on so many levels
with what the gospel actually preaches
that the cognitive dissonance going on
in your head
must be just you know at that peak level
and you're doing it either because you
need to feel good or you hate the those
people over there or you need to like
you know tell yourself somehow that
you're living up to a Christ who's gonna
you ever meet him it's gonna turn your
back his back on you and say that thing
about you and did you clean you know
clothe the naked feed the hungry know
you you you spat on him instead and
elected a guy who treated him like crap
I'll see you later right there's Neil
ISM available underneath all sorts of
stuff and you could be a Neela's
consumerist ooh you could be a nice
centrist and be like I don't want to
hear anybody I just want to play my
video games and enjoy myself and you
know work work the job that I've got or
go to college and do the things that I'm
gonna do but not be bothered by anybody
that's nihilistic - when you get down to
it what is Neil ISM nature said it's the
devaluation of the highest values the
ground sort of drops out doesn't mean
that people don't believe in anything
they believe in things that are [ __ ]
to get by to allow themselves to feel
good about themselves so is there more
of that today than there was in the past
I don't think so
yes honest asks can you explain Kant's
argument for how human freedom makes the
categorical imperative binding it's not
that human freedom makes the categorical
imperative binding it's it's not quite
so direct as that it's you know we can
distinguish between different moral
imperatives right or different
possibilities of imperatives and there
you want to read groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals because he
discusses it in there there's
hypothetical imperatives and those you
know those are like well if you want to
be happy then you should do this right
so you want to be happy through this
then right or if you want to heal a
patient do this and kind
says well those can't really those can't
be truly moral imperatives you need you
need something that could be
universalized there's the first
formulation of the categorical
imperative right human freedom figures a
little bit more into the second
formulation which is that we should you
know always treat humanity as and as an
end as never as a mere means that means
respecting other people as locus of
freedom among other things so respecting
their autonomy which is quite important
but then you know it sound like there's
a one step thing from one to the other
so I think you want to to look at the
groundwork because that that's where
you're gonna find it discussed all right
mister stranger here's a good question
what theory of truth do you subscribe to
I don't subscribe to one theory of truth
I subscribe you a whole bunch of them
because I think they all need to be sort
of combined again I'm an eclectic right
so I you know I think heidegger's got
some cool stuff to say about Allah say I
think he's wrong and saying that it's
the absolute you know foundation for all
the things I think that you know truth
is revealed that as Hegel says the truth
of an idea is often revealed to us in
how it plays itself up practically I
think there's something there I think an
Psalm is onto something in his is a book
on truth talking about truth in the will
Aristotle himself talks about
theoretical and practical truth right
just go to nikka mckay and ethics book
six and you're gonna find an interesting
but under determined discussion of it
there so and you know I like I like the
pragmatists you know I'm not a
pragmatist but they have something good
to say so what we have to do is put them
put them together you know PB Barnett
suggests how about a reading group that
covers one text per month it could meet
online once a month to discuss the text
I'm sure it would get a lot of
participation right now I'm teaching
three classes this summer that all of
which you have to be basically built
from the ground up I'm coming off of a
semester where I taught five classes
I'm heading into another semester where
I'm going to teach six classes that's in
addition to being the editor of Stoicism
today giving roughly 20 free talks here
in the Milwaukee area and I'm carrying
out a whole bunch of other things and
churning about 250 videos the year so I
don't know have that much time for yet
another thing that's in addition to
doing consulting work work with my
clients you know so I don't know I would
have to see I mean I do I've done stuff
like that in the past with my online
classes that are available to the
general public but they're usually
somebody's footing the bill
right it's not it's not just made
absolutely free I did I did offer some
online seminars monthly didn't get a lot
of participation in them unfortunately
you know the videos for them are you can
easily see them they're there they're in
a playlist so I don't know what will
think about it
Jaclyn Shan will you teach some Simone
de Beauvoir in the future or other
female philosophers I did teach the mon
to boudoir this summer and I shot some
videos on her I haven't released the
videos yet so I'll be releasing those
fairly soon I you know when it comes to
female philosophers the ones that I
routinely teach in my classes are de
Beauvoir Mary Wollstonecraft from a huge
fan of sometimes I get to teach Princess
Elizabeth of Bohemia who you know
correspondent with Descartes I'll teach
you know ethics of care thinkers late
20th century ones like Virginia held
Carol Gilligan and rosemary Tong nel
noddings I also teach Han Arendt pretty
frequently and I even teach ayan rant a
lot of people as not a philosophy she's
a philosopher she's just you know not
highly regarded right and you know I I
may end up if I ever have the time doing
some work on Giuliana's stuff because I
think that she's she's really you know
top-notch philosopher so yeah there'll
be more stuff on
female philosophers coming out in terms
of videos and I don't you know I may put
online classes together Wollstonecraft's
would be a natural one for me to do
because I want to do some some academic
work on her as well some article writing
all right
alloy cipher philosophers don't get
enough credit for their badassery
so I have to ask you which philosophers
death was the most badass Socrates was
iconic but I don't think it reached
Cicero's well for those of you don't
know
so Cicero participated in the Roman
civil wars and he fought on the losing
side sorted Kaito Kaito killed himself
Cicero did not sister what comes back to
Rome and eventually you know once things
break down with the second Tran threat
he gets he gets caught and killed by
partisans of Mark Antony and they cut
off his head in his hands and display
them I don't know that that's super
badass you know it was it was cool that
he fought but yeah who else
I mean who comes to mind
I mean speak some philosophers who were
kind of badasses would be Descartes
there's a famous story told about
Descartes you know who fought you know
perfectly fine with enlisting in the
military he he was on a lake one time
and you know he's being rode across it
by these these sailors and he realizes
that they intend to rob him and throw
him overboard so he pulls out his sword
and holds him at sword point until they
get him on the other on the other Shore
right and that probably saved his life I
mean who else there's there's there's
probably plenty of people that we could
we could think of that's that's a good
question Nathan or manned how do you
justify your position as a Christian
I don't have to justify my position
that's a Christian philosopher any more
than you have to justify your position
as whatever it is that you are
Viraj odd didn't candidate that's book
for political philosophy I don't know
that there's a best book I would get
yourself a good anthology that includes
you know a lot of stuff along the way
that that probably would be the thing to
do I know I'm I'm kind of I'm not in
favor of people who want to have just
just the one book so let's see what else
we got here
Ezreal thoughts about am artisan he's
quite influential in development and
welfare economics but here he's cited in
philosophy too exactly yeah he gets
brought up in terms of ethics and
political philosophy for this
development perspective which is
building off of his teacher Rawls but
taking it much further he's well worth
reading and the the discussions about
you know what contributes to and what
constitutes human happiness I think are
worth reading as well sin is one of
those people unfortunately who because
of the nature of classes I'm always like
I wish I could put some of that in there
but I can't I don't have the time to
teach it but yeah somebody who's well
worth worth checking out all right Quinn
Pascal what subjects would you prescribe
for a complete and comprehensive post
high school education for a modern
person do you think it's important for
us to be knowledgeable in different
fields yeah you should know something
about a lot of different fields
I mean philosophy obviously I think
people should study philosophy and I
think they should study multiple
branches of it and not just get their
stuff from Wikipedia or you know short
glitzy YouTube videos I don't name any
names but you guys all know who I'm
talking about
things that are high production a little
content communication is something
people should study and I think you know
probably a study of the emotions of how
they work you know so getting some
degree of emotional intelligence not
something we really do much in school if
you went to a crappy high school or you
went to someplace in a red state you
probably need some some health classes
that actually cover sex ed because I'm
finding out from my own kids how their
education is in Indiana which is a
political matter right
you should learn basic finance that
that's another really key thing how the
financial system works you know what's
gonna happen if you take out credit
cards learning how to budget those sorts
of things
everybody should probably also learn
basic home AK how to cook you know what
goes on when you're cooking things how
to take the stuff in your refrigerator
and turn it into a decent meal and we
could go on and on and on with examples
of things that that people should know
that they're not generally being taught
I think everybody should learn some
foreign languages I think it's I think
it's stupid to not do that you know
maybe you pick the ones that are most
marketable like Spanish or Chinese
you know Mandarin of course although you
know Cantonese could probably be be good
as well
Mandarin will open more doors or no or
you know other other languages as well
if you haven't learned much about music
even if you don't intend to be a
musician you should probably learn a
little bit of music theory and some
music history so you're not just
listening to pop crap all the time and
thinking that's really good say similar
things about art education you know
Theater definitely should learn some
some studies from history it was really
funny I saw something in Twitter the
other day where a historian somebody who
teeth and somebody who teaches in
college is like sometimes I get these
students were like why do we have to
take a history class we already learned
all of our history in high school and
you know that's sort of like what are
you talking about
what you got there was just the thinnest
soil possible even if you take your
required you know one or two history
classes in college you're only going
this deep you you want to learn history
you got to do a lot more than that so I
mean those would be kind of a start I
would say let's see it just jumped a
little bit to do my cypher thanks for
the answer oh you're very welcome
and yeah I am happy to do that now I got
it fine where I was every once in a
while the the live chat thing it'll just
like suddenly scroll down like you know
a million different things so it's hard
and then there's all these side
conversations going on at the same time
that are that are tough to read as well
man where was I oh here we go
bye bye ringing thirteen what's a
powerful argument you have against
physicalism I don't have arguments
against physicalism I I don't you know I
sort of just moved through the the vast
maze that I'm in without worrying so
much about being a proponent of this a
proponent of that you know I'm doing
enough with with just teaching I retro
gamer would you in opinion directly
relate without a detracting critique the
concept of jouissance in Lacan being
equivocal to the pragmatic outcomes of
epicurean values and facilitated growth
of mind so there's a lot of jargon there
that's tough gone back so what is what
is jouissance for Lacan so the French
word you know it's kind of a play on
words um can mean to have an orgasm to
come right
but jouissance is like enjoyment of
things and it's not it's not merely the
there's something beyond the pleasure
you could you could also call it like
satisfaction right
getting what it is that you you want and
very often from like a team perspective
you get what you want and then you
realize this wasn't what I wanted and
sometimes people are telling you you
need to enjoy right that's another
factor of the laconian thing so now
being equivocal yeah the concept is
equivocal or
its meaning that it takes on multiple
meanings right it's it's not something
you can easily tie down equivocal to the
pragmatic outcomes so the payoffs of
epicurean values okay so if you have
epicurean values if I understand the
question right the Epicureans stress
pleasure and that you want to have a
life full of what they called active
pleasures or kinetic pleasures you want
to pursue the one you want to pursue it
rationally so you don't want to just
like immediately throw yourself into the
big party snort a line of coke you know
sort of slamming beers and sleep with
the first person that you come across
because that's liable to be a bad
strategy in attaining pleasure you know
you're gonna wind up with a hangover and
maybe a ticket and an STD and then
you're not gonna be real happy
okay so so you want to be rational in
how you enjoy and consume and and pursue
those pleasures but the Epicureans also
stressed
freedom from fear trouble pain you want
and they and they thought that that
state was actually more enjoyable more
pleasurable than the Epicureans
themselves get in trouble Cicero nails
them he goes after them and book to him
on the ends for being playing fast and
loose with the word pleasureville up
tossing and landing right so that's
that's part of what's going on no how
would Lacan look at that right and how
would you look at in terms of jouissance
so here an epicurean like a classical
epicurean you are without calling it
such you're trying you're being
motivated by what Lacan is calling
Jewish laws there is one other thing
there
a kind of contingency - to that for
Lacan and and I think he's completely
right about this right
we often you know if we're being
rational pleasure maximizers or pursuers
we think to ourselves ah this is going
to get me the pleasure that I want I'm
projecting out of the path ahead this is
what we call practical reasoning and the
Epicureans are very big on that they
said that you can't actually live a
pleasant life without living a prudent
and Justin and and living well so the
prudence part is is practical reason but
we often find you know this is part of
the human condition right we do stuff
and are like that isn't as pleasant as I
thought or we do stuff are like holy
crap this is great right and sometimes
it's just that one time and sometimes
we're able to reproduce it we were able
to make it happen again
so I think that that's probably about as
much as I have to say about both that
right now around Waggoner if I read any
Nicolas Berjaya I have I've read his
book on Dostoevsky and I've read some of
his other stuff but it's been quite a
while since I've read head and so bill
soils what do you think of man's search
for meaning by Viktor Frankl it's a good
book you know it's it's something that
has some interesting parallels with
existentialism and stoicism I actually
knew a person who was super into
logotherapy when I was an undergraduate
and he seemed fairly well adjusted so
you know it's it's certainly a popular
book that's worth reading spiral khatam
Prower regarding uses the dow to
symbolize morality or the way like it's
CS lewis do you know any other moral
combos that the dow could represent I'm
not sure what immoral combo is so I'm
not sure what you're asking there
Michael asks what else can you do with a
PhD in philosophy other than be in the
Academy though i mean google it there's
there's also two articles about that
there's an entire field of people who
are working outside of the Academy and
there's blogs and you know webcasts
devoted to that I've been on some of
those those
podcasts as a guest so that's that's
what I think you can figure out
Charles McLaughlin is liberal Western
civilization now in the pre death
emergency phase espoused by Spengler
with the emergent strongman
authoritarian politics of Trump Putin
and others would suggest we are so
here's what I'll say about that I don't
buy you Spangler myself
Spengler of course could be right about
things if he is then we live in a very
impoverished world because Spangler is
not a you know not a great mic well I
dunno III don't I don't really buy into
that that theory that he's putting
forward I think it's kind of a cookie
cutter approach to history so alright
let's see Bill Olsen asks about vilem
flu saris towards the philosophy of
photography I've never never heard of
them or read him let's see here
T damn League of Legends have I read in
a young if so ordered my thoughts on him
and does his work any have any influence
on philosophy young doesn't have much
influence on philosophy I would say and
I was just talking about this the other
day there's you know there's Union still
practicing out there I think Young has a
much bigger effect on popular culture
I'm getting asked pretty routinely I
think it's because of the Peterson
effect because Peterson is a big Union
you know what I think of the shadow and
stuff like that yeah I've read a lot of
young you know I enjoy reading young but
I don't I don't buy is archetype theory
you know and and I think there's a lot
of like you know neat you know over
comings of dualism there that are a
little bit too neat in the work and I
can see why it appeals to a lot of a lot
of people that said I mean Union
analysis can sometimes help people
psychotherapy it's not like there's one
single approach to psychotherapy that's
good for everybody and and you know
young can be helpful with a good
practitioner I like reading his books
because he's a good stylist but I
I don't really use young at all
Abdul asks can you translate philosophy
without being a professor or expert I'm
studying French lit right now and I'm
interested in translation I'm very
interested in philosophy but I'm just a
layman so it's not like an off on switch
where either yes or no all right it's
it's more like a continuum if you are
translating anything really like if you
wanted me to translate stuff about
toilets and plumbing and in French I
suppose I could do it but I wouldn't be
very good at it you'd probably do better
to have somebody who knew both languages
and actually understood the the field so
it's you know it's gonna be helpful to
know more more about it the other thing
to remember too is that when you get
into authors they often almost have
their own little lexicon that takes you
a while to get used to so alright let's
see what do we got here that's new Derek
Bowser Esther I subscribe to a theory of
aesthetics or have my own view I see
these online neo reactionary types
hammering the subject endlessly is it
very important to our human experience
so I think maybe we're using the word
aesthetics a little bit differently
they're probably tough when when they're
hammering the subject
they're probably advocating like this is
the aesthetic that we want right and
this aesthetics is bad aesthetics in
general is more like well what what
actually constitutes beauty or the
sublime or what's going on when we would
call something art aesthetics isn't
really my feel kind of funny cuz I teach
at Milwaukee Institute of art design and
I suppose I should you know bone up on
it more I took classes on it but I'm not
I'm not an expert on aesthetics and I
can't say I have my own view because I
don't even know other people's views
well enough to have my own view
so yeah all right David divide 7-7 how
do you solve the Euthyphro dilemma by
talking about that in the video on it
it's not it's not a dilemma if there's
other possibilities right
it's only a dilemma if you if you decide
that it isn't one way to solve it is
take one of the horns of the dilemma
right all right let's see here oh we got
about ten minutes left to go in I'm
going to take a pass unfortunately on
Mirek Ahri's question about what Hegel's
talking about when he uses expression of
force and force that's reflected on
itself concepts of the phenomenology
forcing the understanding is the most
difficult part of the phenomenology
spirit one of the most difficult works
of philosophy I'm not sure which video
you're referencing and I certainly don't
have the time to let go it insert you
know looking at the videos so that's
that's something maybe you know I'm
doing half of our Hegel every month I do
like a Q&A and discussion session so you
might want to get in on that you can
find you can find that on my reason I a
website if going to the calendar or by
looking at the Facebook page let's see
what else we can do
Nathan asks how do you deal with the New
Atheism skeptical movement which is
quite popular on YouTube with many
skeptics now studying philosophy at
prestigious universities I don't think
it's new new atheism has been around now
for a couple decades I've never taken it
all that seriously because it's mostly
been bad argumentation and tendentious
you know the skeptical movement skeptic
can mean a million different things some
skeptics are cool and you can work with
them some skeptics are complete jerks
you know and I like to debate me bro you
know sort of thing and there is not
worth my time
I will have to take it for granted that
there's many of them now studying
philosophy at prestigious universities I
don't care about prestigious
universities if you know if you've know
me at all
you know that I think that you can do
philosophy just as well and a you know
low tier University is you can add a
high tier University I think that you
know from my own experience everybody
puts their pants on you know the same
way one leg at a time even if you have a
valet to do it for you I'm not impressed
by buy prestige
and it doesn't strike me as a major
issue let's see a lot of back and forth
going on here some of these it's hard to
tell whether the questions for me or
people asking each other questions mm
okay here's an interesting one from
long-term participant whose name I
always screw up nice myst and then can
we construct new conceptual frameworks
for people to construct a census
communis of common sense right sort of
agreed-upon basis that could help us
with climate crisis that is that is the
concept of limitation to our everyday
consciousness we could but we wouldn't
be able to get a lot of people who need
to be on board on board I think that
that's a good question can we form could
we form a consensus so it's not just
like all these different groups that
don't agree with each other can we
arrive at the point where we're like man
we'd better do something about climate
because we're getting ourselves into
deep territory whatever degree it's man
you know human-caused we're really
contributing a lot to our our problems
that that future generations are going
to face and maybe we're going to make
the earth uninhabitable for just a small
pocket of humans which seems to be a
terrible idea yeah I mean we could we
that but it's it's so difficult to get
people out of there
current mindsets and not just on the
right I mean the right bears way more
responsibility particularly here in
America where they you know staked out
stupid irrational positions from a sort
of human race perspective and you know
if history if we have a history later
we're gonna look back and be like man
half the population were dummies you
know intransigent dummies but there's
plenty of problems on the left too I
mean you're not doing anybody any favors
by getting into weird you know new agey
conspiracy theory stuff about you know
the planet being alive there's you know
mankind doing this or that that's that's
so terrible we have to have some very
very pragmatic solutions to this and I
don't know how to how to provide it so
but it's a great question
Aaron asks is it beneficial to you if
you break down philosophical concepts
into their logical functions like a
bare-bones representation yes and no yes
if they're amenable to that no if doing
so leaves out so much that your
bare-bones representation no longer has
anything remotely like what's actually
being presented great example of that
that I mentioned at the beginning all
these reconstructions that people do of
you know what was Anselm's argument
really about right there in the text
read the Proust load you also read the
motor while GM right read the other
works as well but you know the the
reconstructions that I've seen almost
always deviate in some way sometimes
they're bringing something in sometimes
they're just too reductionist so those
are two ways you can you can go wrong in
doing that and and it's good to remember
too that a lot of the available material
out there on philosophers that you're
going to get through popular internet
sources or philosophy textbooks is is of
that reductive like I'm going to make it
bare-bones for you so think about like
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics and the
function argument
I mean if Aristotle wanted to give you a
the function argument he would have done
it right
he wouldn't written all that other stuff
surrounding the passages that that they
focus on so that other stuff is
important all right let's see here fish
spirit wants to be challenging
non-aligned equals fascist I guess maybe
for you there's plenty of ways to be
non-aligned that aren't fascist and I
would distrust the mentality of anybody
who can have an equal sign and fascist
so you kind of out in yourself here
let's see here to do scrolling down oh
there's an interesting question from
from Owen about pedagogy do I think
students should have more or less module
choice at undergrad philosophy meaning
I'm guessing should they be able to
decide what undergrad philosophy classes
they want to take and then we're not
just saying about majors right because
they they have choices about what they
want to take but should like students
who are non majors who have to take some
philosophy classes should they get a
choice about that or should it be
dictated you're taking critical thinking
body or you're taking intro and ethics
or something like that um I think that
you know it depends on the educational
institution it could be quite good for
them to be to have a choice but it
should be a fairly narrow range of
choices you don't want students like
jumping into a 400 level class with no
background whatsoever then again simply
taking intro to philosophy which is
usually a prereq for those upper-level
classes often depending on who the
instructor is might not be all that
helpful so alright let me if I can find
some other people I haven't already
answered they'd have some some good easy
to answer questions to do to do
look just skip it down a bit so oh so
here's here's a good good question a :
11 have you read see Kevin Rose one true
life the Stoics and early Christians as
rival traditions if so what do you think
of his thesis that their differences are
irreconcilable I haven't read it got it
on my shelf it's there I got sent a copy
to review but I'm familiar with the
thesis and it depends on what we mean by
differences are irreconcilable if we
want to say all differences are
irreconcilable that's bullsháá I mean
all we got to do is actually read early
Christian thinkers and see that that's
not the case because they talked about
the Stoics right and some of them said
it oh the Stoics are right about this
and you can look at you know others who
used appropriated struck techniques if
you're saying that on on at some points
there's going to be some ways or the
Stoics go this way and Christians go
this way yeah I mean that's the way it
is with pretty much every rival
philosophical tradition you could say
the same thing about the Aristotelian
zon the Stoics there's some things where
the Aristotelian and the Stoics are
actually on the same page somewhere
they're marginally different from each
other but in conversation somewhere
one's going this way in one's going this
way that is the nature of traditions
sometimes you got to pick and choose
you can't put everybody always on the
same page and pretend you know in a new
age anyway that we're all doing the same
thing man so I don't know
oh I'm certainly looking forward to
reading the book when I can find the
time but yeah okay let's see let me pick
one more question and then we're gonna
we're going to come to an end with that
[Music]
scroll down a little bit
a lot of repeats of questions in here
that people are doing again well so
there's a question that that's asked
hear about Camus and the question itself
okay who can we read as an opposite
opinion to Camus or whoever criticizing
kombu I mean other eggs of people who
were in the existential spectrum I know
I can Lou says he's not an essentials he
is an existentialist he's just using the
word existentialism more narrowly you
know Gabrielle Marcel Simone de Beauvoir
Sartre
they're they're not all in total
agreements about things who else would
you read criticizing Camus it's been why
you're you're you're why you're trying
to find criticisms I mean you could
easily find people saying the standard
line he's not much of a philosopher is
you more moralist or a novelist which i
think is crap actually quite frankly but
it is style certainly is rather opaque
in many accounts I actually I like
comment quite a bit I'm much more
attracted to his political position than
I am
many of the other existentialist writers
you know what he articulates in in the
rebel I think is well worth taking into
account letters to a German friend but
if you want to criticize him you know I
would I would look to other people in
that that same time and spectrum so
we're almost we're all we're really
actually out of time and I have to do
some class prep because I'm teaching all
sorts of stuff but let's see if there's
not anything else I could knock out very
quickly to finish up with
Wow some people have a lot of very
esoteric things but they're asking about
here
I always wrap it up I do have to get
going I have to build more content for
this business ethics class that I'm
currently teaching and get cracking on
content for a class that I'll be
teaching for prisoners in the fall which
has to be completely ready to roll as an
online class when classes begin so I'll
say thanks
we'll be doing some philosophy pop-ups
later in the month there's also the half
hour Hegel question answer and
discussion session as I mentioned and
I've got another studying philosophy
independently Sadler's advice video
coming out provided I get a shot over
this coming week next Saturday on
epicurean philosophy so if you're kind
of a fan of that or wanted to get into
that you might want to check that out
thanks everybody to ask questions
obviously I didn't get to all of them
but we never do so hope you have a great
day wherever you happen to be in the
world good morning - or afternoon or
evening or night or whatever it is so
I'll see all of you in the ether